you were watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
when Facebook first went online in 2004
there's nothing more than a fledgling
website since then the social media
network has captured over 2 billion
unique monthly users because of this
Facebook has been a social media icon
for the past decade swallowing Instagram
and whatsapp in its wake but lately
attitudes towards Facebook are changing
and as a result Facebook is dying from
accusations of causing mental harm to
data and security concerns everybody
seems to have had it with the social
media giant and the trend is growing
beyond Facebook in this video we'll take
a look at the surprising new statistics
of how people are leaving Facebook then
we'll see why it's happening and then
end with a fascinating look at social
media in general and how it's affecting
our society
so how exactly is Facebook dying young
people are leaving Facebook and droves
according to recent data by the Pew
Research Center that sampled us Facebook
users 18 and up 42 percent have taken a
break from the social network for
several weeks or more to add to this 44
percent of users aged 18 to 29 deleted
Facebook's app in recent months it might
take some time for Facebook to myspace
itself but 44 percent of young Americans
deleting the app is very alarming for
Facebook it shows an incredible shift in
attitude in fact I'd say a lot of the
remaining people on Facebook only keep
the app for the messenger function or
the events page feature this research
data could be a stark leading indicator
for the company and social media as a
whole people are just over Facebook and
some are getting sick of social media in
general it was the first thing I would
do you know in the morning you it when
when you catch yourself going for that
phone like your eyes open and like even
before your first stop or impulse to pee
and choose your head the phone is the
first impulse that's sick it was making
me unhappy because you're always
thinking about all these other people
you're worrying about all these other
people what they're doing and and you're
not living in the physical world but you
don't even think about what's in front
of you people are in front of you every
you know the physical world and I have
this feeling too that spending so much
time on social media actually impairs my
thoughts I feel like I don't think as
clearly or as freely because it
literally just is it is a distraction so
let's take a look at some reasons of why
the social media giant is rapidly
falling out of favor
empathy is the ability to feel or
understand another person's perspective
it's putting yourself in someone else's
shoes basically asking ourselves
internally what if that was me empathy
is one of the major elements of humanity
that prevents us from displaying
animalistic tendencies social media has
obliterated empathy in the past few
years and it's starting to show a
blatant disregard for human life
a group of Florida teens taunt a
drowning man while filming his final
moments from afar the five teen boys
between the ages of 14 and 16 can be
heard laughing as the man struggles to
stay afloat in a pond in Cocoa Florida
rather than call for help the teens
recorded the incident on cell phone
chuckling while they watched the man die
they say this when the man goes
underwater and doesn't resurface
terrible but familiar things happen when
empathy goes away as empathy destruction
continues you'll start seeing angry
swarms of people demanding death to
another person without fully
understanding the circumstances or
taking the effort to comprehend how the
accused was feeling when they did or
said something controversial you've
probably seen this kind of thing all
over the internet recently of course
there are political and social movements
riding on top of this but I have a hunch
that empathy destruction is close to the
heart of why this is happening the
reduction of empathy is even more
evident in younger developing minds but
neuro scientists in BC may have found
answers in science when you're engaged
with your phone or something external
these areas that are involved in
daydreaming and thinking about your own
thoughts and feelings shut off the
answers maybe in the brain see that blue
area of the brain that's the area that
learns empathy what they found is that
those areas that learn empathy are only
active when you do nothing when you
daydream and that's something today's
teenagers don't do kids are constantly
engaged with their technology their
phones and the Internet
they're not activating these brain areas
that are important for self-reflection
and reflecting on other people
and allowing that empathy to emerge the
Institute for Social Research found
college students to be 40 percent lower
in empathy than those in the 1990s the
study looked at things like helping a
stranger carry their belongings allowing
someone ahead of them in life or just
helping a friend another study found
that modern students seem to be much
more self concerned individualistic
competitive and confident while some of
these traits are good in small doses
when over-represented they can be quite
negative on average 18 to 24 year olds
spend 12% of their life on social media
with those kind of numbers there has to
be some impact high social media use has
been linked to anxiety depression and
stress a 2015 report by Penn State
University's Center for mental health
recorded a drastic rise in the three
diagnoses the reason for this state of
affairs can be described as follows when
on social media our expectations of life
are sky-high and that's because of what
we see everybody looks and is perfect
they're always doing something cool and
it becomes oh so easy to ask oneself why
isn't my life like that it can be said
that comparison is the depletion of joy
to add to this Millennials and
generations said have a tough a lot in
life lower earnings inflation and scarce
job prospects make a dream lifestyle
difficult there becomes this disconnect
between reality and perceived reality
which can result in great sorrow but the
truth is those perfect moments that are
posted by others are very carefully
selected and things may not be so
perfect behind the scenes most social
media platforms and Facebook in
particular take part in hacking human
nature engineers that these companies
have exploited the biological dopamine
reward pathways in our brains just to
get us to spend more time on these sites
for example a person might continue to
scroll on Facebook because finding a
post that they enjoy and releases
dopamine so they'll keep scrolling until
they find it likes comments and shares
also release dopamine in our brains
unfortunately for some this can lead to
a very real addiction similar to
chemical dependency on drugs
[Music]
who worked with Mark Zuckerberg to
develop Facebook with a bombshell claim
how do we consume as much of your time
and conscious attention as possible it's
a social validation feedback loop
because you're exploiting a
vulnerability in in human psychology the
38 year old mogul admits he along with
other pioneers of social media knew what
they were doing we understood this
consciously and we did it anyway you've
probably noticed that the Internet is
turning more and more divisive nobody
can seem to talk to each other without
getting angry but why apart from low
empathy causing detachment from other
points of view there might be another
additional reason the dunning-kruger
effect the dunning-kruger effect was
proposed by David Dunning and Justin
Kruger in 1999 it states that if a
person has limited knowledge on a topic
they'll be extremely confident in what
they're saying and grossly overestimate
their abilities but as the person gains
more knowledge they might begin to
realize that things are much more
complicated than they first thought as
more knowledge is gained one becomes
less sure about what they're talking
about they only start to become
confident again when they approach
expert levels of knowledge as you can
imagine internet discussions aren't full
of experts so if we apply this theory to
social media conversations we should
expect to see this the people who know
the least will be commenting the most
because they're the most confident and
those who have the most knowledge will
be more likely to stay out of comment
wars because they're less confident as
for the true experts they're few and far
between the dunning-kruger effect
combined with empathy destruction and
create an environment where those with
the least knowledge of a most vocal yet
are unable to comprehend opposing points
of view and at the same time the more
informed people are likely to stay
silent
ladies and gentlemen social media in a
nutshell never before have we seen the
dunning-kruger effect so widespread
globally and I think people are starting
to get tired of the nonsense that it
creates but combining this phenomena
with social media makes this problem go
a whole lot further
he's former Facebook executive chap
math.pow Hypatia talking truthfully
about how social media is ripping the
very fabric of society apart you said
that this is a time for soul-searching
in social media businesses and and you
were part of building the largest one
what soul-searching are you doing right
now on that I feel tremendous guilt even
though we feigned this whole line of
like there probably aren't any really
bad unintended consequences I think in
the back
deep deep recesses of our minds we we
kind of knew something bad could happen
but I think the way we defined it was
not like this it literally is a point
now where I think we have created tools
that are ripping apart the social fabric
of how society works that is truly where
we are if you feed the beast that beast
will destroy you if you push back on it
we have a chance to control it and rein
it in and it is a point in time where
people need to hard break from some of
these tools and the things that you rely
on the short term dopamine driven
feedback loops that we have created our
destroying how society works no civil
discourse no cooperation misinformation
miss truth this is a global problem
mental health concerns and the
disintegration of civil conversation
have been brewing for years but I think
the most recent reason for the Exodus
and Facebook was due to the Cambridge
analytical scandal people just didn't
like their personal information being
taken and sold in the open market this
was the straw that broke Facebook's back
was the privacy concerns that finally
woke people up
so what can we conclude from all of this
at first it seems a little confronting
but on the bright side people are
starting to understand that social media
isn't healthy if misused or overused and
that's generally how society works we
discover something new and then realize
that it's not good for us and then
eventually we swing back to an
equilibrium even Google and Apple have
implemented something called digital
well-being in their latest versions of
their smartphone software its aim is to
encourage people to use their phones
less as a whole it seems like we're
reaching a turning point with social
media people are sick of how they feel
when they use it so hearing all of this
you might get the idea that social media
is inherently bad but it's not for
example Facebook is great for keeping in
contact with friends and family in other
countries it's important to remember the
following social media isn't the enemy
it's just a tool that's an amplified
reflection of us we need to take
responsibility for ourselves
hopefully videos like this might spread
awareness in the emerging problems that
we're starting to see we need empathy we
have to be willing to imagine what other
people who are different from us
experience if you don't want to do this
at least give it a thought if not we'll
be giving in to impulsive animal-like
instincts and we're better than them as
for Facebook their ownership of
Instagram and whatsapp may be integral
to their survival in the future
ultimately we'll have to wait and see
what happens
so that's it that was a look at Facebook
social media in general and it's darker
side so let me know a few things in the
comments do use social media in general
and if you do what platform do you use
the most often let me know
so thanks for watching this has been
together if you just stumble across this
channel feel free to subscribe I'm sure
you'll find lots of interesting stuff
I'll catch you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]